[MUSIC]
Well, one interesting thing about the
algorithms that predict future behavior
and psychological traits or intimate
traits of people is that, people often
think, my good this is science fiction
you know like how could that be or
they say my god this
is totally impossible.
Now, it's in fact pretty intuitive.
Look, if you know someone pretty well,
you will be able to predict
their future behavior.
Even if you don't know exactly
whether they've read a given book or
not, you're reading this book now and
you think my God.
The friend of mine,
the one that is so well organized and
always talks about this given thing,
here she would really love this book.
What you made here, you made a prediction.
Right you know your friend.
You know their psychological traits.
You know some of them intimate traits.
And it allows you to extrapolate from the
knowledge you have about the friend into
new areas.
You basically see a new book or see a new
play or hear about a new activity and
you can predict which on of
your friends would like it.
Now, computers basically computer
algorithm do exactly the same thing
they would take set of behaviors that
a given person has expressed in the past.
Now match it with behavior of many
other people that the algorithm has in
its database and then say, hey you
know people who read these books or
people who listen to this type of music or
people who visit these websites.
They also tend to vote conservative or
study psychology or work as accounts.
So now we can basically, you just
make those very simple predictions.
And when I say it simple but
then on a large scale,
it basically become very powerful.
A lot of signal that useful for
an algorithm would not be useful for
a human being.
Let me give you an example.
If I tell you the politicians that I like,
you'll have no trouble figuring
out what my political views are.
Perhaps, even if I gave you
ten of my favorite books,
it will be still informative
to you as a human being.
Okay, so people who read those books,
they tend to have this political leaning,
or this religious leaning, and so on.
But now if I told you, look, those
are the ten games I've played recently,
or this is the brand of
the shoes that I'm wearing,
now as a human being you'll be like yeah,
it's probably not very revealing
by your political views or
religiosity simply because
it's kind of difficult for
us to match a brand of a shoe or a game
with particular ideology or world view.
Now, the fact that it's difficult for
us to see the link,
doesn't mean that the link doesn't exist.
Right?
The link could there,
it just could be subtle enough to fall
below our threshold of perception.
Now, a computer has a big advantage here.
It can store and
process way more data than
humans can in terms of length and
their relationships like that.
So it might be that when you look at a
huge database of millions of other people,
it might be that people that wear a given
brand of shoes they have a slight
liberal or conservative leaning, something
that would be imperceptible for humans.
For a computer,
it's a useful bit of information.
A useful bit of information
that is not conclusive.
But now, if you add up thousands or
millions of little crumbs of
inconclusive information like that,
you can in fact arrive at
the very accurate profile.
[MUSIC]
To answers this question, we collected
a lot of digital footprints and
we use Facebook as our
research environment.
We ask people to share of us
there Facebook likes, and
Facebook status updates.
And then we also asked the same
participants to feel in questionnaires,
personality questionnaires,
IQ questionnaires,
happiness questionnaires, and so on.
And then we build machine learning
models that would predict the scores of
these people on these questionnaires
from the digital footprints.
And once we've done that,
we would take a group of new participants
that the algorithm has never seen before.
And we would try to predict their scores
on self imported questionnaires which
we used to measure the accuracy
of the algorithmic approach to
measure your psychological traits.
And it turns out those methods
are very highly accurate.
To give you an example, we compared
that curiosity of these algorithms,
of the algorithms based on Facebook likes,
with that curiosity of human judges.
We would give questions,
personality questions in this case.
To friends and family members of our
participants, and would ask them to
fill in those questionnaires in
the name of the participants, right?
So based on the acquaintance
with the participant who
are supposed to answer
the questionnaire in their names.
So, then what you would get?
You would get basic personality
scores of the participants,
as predicted by their friends and
family members.
And, then on the other hand,
we had their scores,
as predicted by the computer algorithm
based on their Facebook likes.
And now we could compare,
how many likes do you need
to be as accurate as a given friend or
family member.
And what we found is that
you need only ten likes.
You need to give algorithm
only ten likes for
the algorithm to be as
accurate as your work put in.
You need around 100 likes for
the algorithm to be as accurate when
predicting your personality as your family
member like brother or mother would be.
And finally, you need around 200 likes to
beat the most accurate of human judges,
your own spouse.
[MUSIC]
So in the past if I wanted to know your
political views either I needed to
basically become close with you, and
have you share those views with me.
Though, we know that even close friends,
where you often do not
discuss certain ideas, and
do not share all of the information, all
of their intimate traits with each other.
Now, I could also give you
a questionnaire in the past.
And ask you hey can you please fill
this questionnaire, and you get
full control over, hey what are you going
to respond to this questionnaire or not.
And if you decided to respond to this
questionnaire, you still have a choice
of not answering the questions honestly
which basically means that you had
full control, one could say,
or a large degree of control
over your intimate traits that you did
not want to share with the others.
Now, if I can make the same predictions,
if I can predict your intimate traits such
as your political views, sexual
orientation, religiosity, personality,
intelligence or
whether your parents were divorced or not.
If I can predict all of those
things by simply providing
an algorithm with the list of
songs that you have listened to or
the list of websites that you
have visited in recent hours or
days, this basically means that we
are heading towards the post-privacy era,
a time where people will
not have rights to privacy.
[MUSIC]
When I started studying these algorithms,
I was mostly focused on the downside.
I thought it was very scary that.
You can have a computer algorithm
that takes seemingly innocent and
seemingly uninformative piece of data
such as your playlist on Spotify or
a bunch of Facebook likes, and can
extrapolate from these data to make very
accurate predictions about your intimate
traits such as your political views,
religiosity, sexual orientation,
personality, IQ and so on.
This was pretty scary for me, I did not
expect the algorithms to be as accurate.
I thought well, there will be some
accuracy, but we quickly learnt that
the accuracy of the algorithms is
higher than what people could achieve.
And it also hired then what's
could be done with questionnaires,
especially in times of trade that
people are not happy to share
with the others like you don't
really share your political views or
your sexual orientation with people
that you don't know really well.
And I think it only appeared later
to me that, there are risks there,
but are also tremendous opportunities,
let's say to make the world a safer and
more fair place as in matching
people with better jobs or
let's say monitoring their
psychological health.
And extending those benefits to people
who are traditionally deprived of it.
[MUSIC]
Well, I think that people are really
willing to share their data and
give up their data, simply because
it's really beneficial to us.
Right, think about Google Maps.
It's an amazing tool that helps
us to get from point a to
point b in the shortest possible time and
while burning the least fuel.
It's amazing both on the personal
level but also on the societal level.
We're saving a lot of hours and
a lot of gallons of fuel,
which is also great for
environment and so on.
Now, for Google Maps to work, what
basically need to happen is that you can
use it to find your way to work but also
you have share the information about how
you were driving around with the platform.
Because then the platform
can use this data,
that it collected from you,
to optimize the routes for other people.
Right, so,
I think there's no going back from here.
People get so much in return for
sharing the data.
That it's unlikely that they will now
willing to give up Google, Google Maps,
Facebook, Amazon, Kindle, Netflix,
and all of the other platforms that
basically make our lives easier, safer,
more interesting, fulfilling, and so on.
[MUSIC]
Well, I think we certainly
need good legislation and
good technology to help us to
maintain as much privacy as possible.
But I think that in the long term,
the game here is lost.
The sooner we accept that we are heading
towards the future without privacy,
the sooner we can focus on trying
to organize these societies and
organize the policies technology and
even cultures in such a way as to
accommodate the world's Without privacy.
To large extent,
it is an uncharted territory.
What in the past required
huge institutions,
spying on people,
trying to predict their intimate traits,
keeping tabs on them required enormous
amount of effort, money and men power.
Today, the same thing can be achieved
by a guy in a dorm room with a laptop and
Internet connection.
And a few hundred dollars to
spend on databases that can be
purchased on official or
an official data markets,
which basically completely
changes the game.
And l think the sooner the people accept
the fact that basically there is no
privacy going forward, the safer
the society would become, the sooner you
realize wherever you are writing your
email can be read by motivated others.
The sooner that we all realize that
being an atheist or being gay or
being liberal or conservative is something
that a basic in people know about,
well, they could probably
very easily infer it now and
definitely will just get
easier in the future.
The sooner we can focus on making
societies more tolerant and open-minded.
Educating the voters to make them
more difficult to manipulate and
basically organizing the societies and
preparing them for post-privacy era.
[MUSIC]